- Welcome. My name is
OrLando, Yarborough the third.
and there's some index cards
being passed out and pens.
And as more people come in,
we'll continue to give those cards.
I do wanna just take a
moment and acknowledge
and remember Tom Lawrence
and just to have a moment
of silence for us.
So I ask for us to have
a moment of silence
right now, please.
Thank you.
I want to invite Jemimah, a
graduating senior on campus,
a freshmen counselor,
first year counselor.
So just come and greet us.
(audience applauding)
- Good evening, everyone and welcome.
My name is Jemimah. Jemimah Orevaoghene.
As said, I'm a senior on
campus, but most importantly,
welcome to everyone.
If you can yell, give
yourself a round of applause.
(audience applauding)
Okay, so you're on Yale's
campus on a Wednesday night,
y'all know you're gonna
do better than that.
So can you give yourself
better round of applause?
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
So welcome to our town hall
with Lecrae on the intersection
of mental health, faith,
culture, and social justice.
And genuinely from everyone
who organized this,
thank you so much for being
here and now I would like
to invite Karnessia
Georgetown to come and serve
as our opening MC, can you
give her a round of applause?
(audience applauding)
Hey everybody, I'm Karnessia,
but I'm really here
because I have the pleasure
of introducing you all
to one of our student,
wonderful student performers.
And then I'll get to introduce
Professor Addy as well.
But just to say a little bit
about my friend Anita Norman.
(audience applauding)
(Karnessia cheering)
Anita is a senior here at Yale college.
She's majoring in American
studies with a focus on,
let me make sure I get this right,
with a focus on visual
and performing arts,
which is really awesome.
And I had the pleasure
of having her in one
of, a docu-series that I've
produced and she just blew
us away by just her radiance
and the light that she brings.
And actually I did some
stalking online (laughs)
and she is a 2014 Poetry Out
Loud world national champion,
and has just been, that's
incredible. (applauds)
She has been asked to
come back multiple times
to inspire you.
And she did a poem that
won her or got her to like
the final stages.
And it was called, I think
I'm right about this,
"Let the Light in", right?
"Let the Light in", found that
on the website. But, anyway.
And so I think though, I was like, oh,
that's interesting that
she did something like
"Let the Light in" because I
think that's what she does.
And so she brings light
to whatever room she's in.
So I hope that you all would enjoy her.
I know that you all will,
and I'll be back to introduce
Professor Addy after that.
(audience applauding)
- Hello, everyone!
I am from Little Rock, Arkansas,
but also Memphis, Tennessee.
And I grew up in the Southern Black Church
and Mabel Moore is my great-grandmother.
I'm gonna talk about her a little bit.
And she would just
absolutely have a, I'll fit,
you know, a hernia or something
if she knew that I was
reading from a paper.
So don't tell her, okay?
(audience laughs)
But some things have changed
and I've been thinking
a lot about recent events on
campus and just my time here.
So I wrote something else
and that's why it's on paper.
And to me, home is essential
for centering and grounding.
And I think that we have
the potential to create
home in ourselves.
It doesn't have to be a
place, a physical place,
but in the interactions that
we have with one another,
oftentimes Yale students
complain, it's not genuine,
we ask the same questions,
we say the same things,
and my goal for the year and my goal
in this introduction is
just to remind us that we do
come from someplace.
Remember those things
that make you excited,
that make your eyes well up,
or that make you just crack up.
I will be making a lot
of references about home.
So it's about culture,
it's about mental health
and it's about faith.
And hopefully that comes across.
Here is a bunch of little vignettes.
This is for the brother
that flipped a coin
that always landed on heads.
There was never a 50-50 chance,
God always knew for certain,
this is my busted lip and
black eye 'cause round one
never ends up running around
the block up the stairs
when mama is yelling,
"Didn't I tell you to water my garden!"
And I was just stargazing in my...
And singing ritual on my
way to the gas station
for a pickle.
Hubba Bubba and Double
Dutch, skipping rocks
and fishing rods.
Realizing, growing up is
an obligation to my younger
self to be all the beauty
I saw in butterflies
breaking their backs every
time they dare to fly.
This is Sarah Vaughan and
Billie Holiday laughing
at dream deferred, I stole
it back and grew it up.
And my naps stacked
can't touch them. (sings)
Okay.
When I realized I was a lamppost,
I was staring at the
collarbone of magnolia trees
who birthed sunlight from beneath eyelids
that whisper sleepy dreams,
celestial braids flowing down my back
as my great-grandmother
greased an itchy scalp, oil,
dug her fingers in the side of my arm,
said you got breath
flowing like windows down
on highway 365.
Don't roll them up, baby.
Don't forget what you know.
We face our fears at the
fulcrum of alone and awake
and lucid, meet our demons on the curb.
In passing.
When I realized I had seen one,
she had a cigarette
dangling from her lips,
reaching in her bag for another.
She asked me for a lighter.
How easily we infatuate
ourselves and vacuums of empty.
On a real, I've been sitting
in the open of my windows
for days, where leaves
fold into romantic getaways
and the intimacy of their
brush is like the way I wish
our words would fold into
the corners of each other,
waxing a warm sort of world,
but it all fades to black.
I know how bees make
honey sweet and how seeds
become dandelions, field
formations for wishes come true.
I know that tears fall
in the shape of rain,
torrential downpours
happen inside the folds
of a pillowcase.
I know about sitting on
blankets on the back porch
with my cousin pilling corn
husks, talking about nothing.
Seems like those were the best times.
I know about broken plates
and the hours it takes
to glue them together.
I'm know people break too.
I know about circles, the deep ones,
that make my face into a shadow of itself,
they take light with them and
make eyes into just sockets.
I know about disappearing,
finding a mirror and talking
things back into existence.
There's a ledge.
And I know about letting
my feet dangle till
the roaring ceases to
make my stomach boil.
I know about light rooms
that feel like dark rooms
and loud rooms that
feel like lonely rooms.
I know in some places,
the clouds seem closer to
you than they do the sky.
And the sun takes up the whole
horizon. Sit here with me.
We know, in some places
the cloud seem closer to us
than they do the sky,
and the sun takes up the whole horizon.
An interlude.
To grow an ocean,
you stick a cloud on the
tip of your tongue and blow!
A prayer, a raging plea
for bursting ground,
a righteous peace.
I have been dreaming of
spirits that sit in the train,
on a bus, in a tree, at the table.
Something you walk
through that catches hands
and spins merry go rounds in our sorrow.
Ancestral souls whose backs
cracked open and yoked
the hope holes, yolk the holes full again.
I do not mean to trivialize
or beautify the ugly.
I only mean to create a home,
a heart that bleeds seeds
of divine qualification.
He who collects all my tears in a bottle,
records them in a book.
I didn't write that. That was in Psalms.
He, who burns the book
and writes new ones,
the spirit that I walk through.
I do not mean to trivialize
or beautify the ugly.
I only mean to create a home.
A whimsical sort of freedom,
unbound and wailing.
♪ All we wanna do is
break the chains off ♪
♪ All you wanna do is be free ♪
J. Cole.
An interlude.
The leftover bacon grease
from the pot I cooked
in last night stays smeared
on the kitchen counter.
I hope the ant I saw crawling
up the cabinet gets stuck.
Visitors are always welcome in my home.
I peel the potato and
then a cucumber and then
an apple and the carrot
and some corn and then some
squash and an onion, and
then a Brussel sprout,
and then the beans and also a tangerine.
Eat with me. I only mean to create a home.
(audience applauding)
- See, I told Josh she was
gonna let that light in.
That was incredible.
And if it feels like that
deserves an award, like,
I feel like we're like 20 years from now,
we're bringing her back
to do that, you know?
And so that's just Anita for you.
And I think that's just like a glimpse.
And also I forgot to
mention that she's directing
a play called "Billing Basins".
This semester she's also the coordinator
for Black Church at Yale.
So she's just doing incredible things
on this campus, right?
And I think that she is
somebody to know and to love.
And so now I have the
pleasure to introduce
professor Nii Addy.
Professor Addy received
his BS at Duke University
and his PhD here at Yale in neuroscience.
And he's been a Yale
faculty member since 2010.
And so I'm gonna read
Professors Addy's last research,
'cause it's kinda a
little out of my realm,
but it's super dope.
(audience laughs)
So Dr. Addy's research focuses
on neurobiological basis
of substance abuse,
anxiety and depression,
but goals of his research
are to provide new
mechanistic insight into
the psychiatric illnesses
and to identify novel therapeutic
targets for treatment.
Outside of the laboratory,
Dr. Addy regularly contributes
to science outreach
events from middle and
high school students
and the general public.
In addition, he serves
in several mentorship
and leadership roles related
to diversity and inclusion,
both here at Yale and nationally.
He has also had the honor of participating
in multiple college
campuses various forums
on the biological,
psychological and spiritual
aspects of mental health.
So please join me in welcoming
Professor Addy to the stage.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for that
generous introduction.
It's great to see a full house tonight.
We've been really encouraged by,
just the conversations
that've already started
even before we have this
official conversation tonight.
So I'm thankful for all of
you for coming out tonight.
I'm thankful for the
enthusiasm and motivation
that people have had to
really have this conversation.
Also wanted to thank all those
who've already participated,
Anita, Karnessia and also
Jemimah and Pastor OrLando,
and for all the work
that Black Church at Yale
has put into this event as well.
So let's give them a round of applause.
(audience applauding)
Also wanted to give a
special thanks to my cohost,
So both Sharon Kugler,
the university chaplain,
who's here in the front.
If we can give her an
acknowledgement as well.
(audience applauding)
And Pastor OrLando, who's
the other co-host with me,
and they both put in a lot
of work to really getting
this off the ground.
So we're pleased to have
everyone here tonight.
So as she mentioned, I'm a
neuroscientist and a researcher.
So one of the pieces that I
obviously think about quite
a bit is the component of mental health.
And I can say that on our campus,
we have made a lot of strides in terms
of how we talk about mental health,
focusing in particular
on trying to decrease
the stigma that's associated
with those conversations.
But clearly there's still
a lot of room for growth
in these conversations and
we still have a lot to do.
And I would say that's not something
that's just so unique to our campus,
but it's also true nationwide.
Again, where there's been lots of places
where there's been improvement
in the conversation,
but still room for growth and something
that we're hoping to
continue to facilitate
through the conversation tonight.
So we're really thankful
that Lecrae is actually
taking the time out of his
busy schedule to join us here.
I know this is a topic
that's very important
to him as well.
And I can tell you that
his schedule is very crazy.
So, just in working with
his team and all the nuances
and things that we tried
to manage over time
and really thankful for his investment
in our topic tonight and thankful for all
of you being willing to
be here and to really jump
into this conversation with us.
Now, to introduce Lecrae,
I could stick to kind
to kind of the standard bio and just talk
about of the accomplishments
that he's had.
And for any of you who know about him,
we know this wouldn't
be that difficult to do.
He's won multiple Grammy
awards, multiple BET awards,
Dove Awards, he has had a New
York times bestselling book,
he's had multiple appearances on BET,
Good Morning America, The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon,
just to name a few.
So obviously I can give him
some time to flex a little
bit if he wants to when it comes up here,
but for this part of the introduction,
I wanted to step outside
of those accomplishments
a little bit and talk
a little bit about some
of his influence in other areas as well.
So one of the things I've
been really impressed
and kind of watching his
career and development
over the years is how well
he's really able to step
into lots of different
venues and different spaces
and to be able to connect with people
with an authentic voice.
And I think that's a real gifting.
I think it's something
that's allowed him to really
engage in deep and rich
conversations with people
and to have impact in
people's lives as well.
I was actually witness to
that even earlier today
when we had a small
group gathering with some
students here and again,
just seeing his ability to really engage
in those challenging, real
and tough conversations
and to really have impact.
So I'm grateful that he's
taken time out to come here
and to be engaged in that
conversation with us here.
So the way that this
event actually came about,
I had the opportunity to
meet Lecrae at event back
in April, and basically
just from our conversation
and talking about some
of these types of things,
it was really clear to
me that this was a topic
that really resonated with him.
So this intersection of
mental health, faith, culture,
and social justice.
And basically tonight's
event was really birthed
out of our mutual desire
to see this conversation
on a much larger scale.
So what we're really hoping for tonight
is that this would really
just be the beginning.
We don't want this to be a one-time event.
We want this to be a
conversation that starts now,
or that continues now and
continues beyond tonight as well.
But for tonight, what
we're really trying to do
is make sure that we can
really have a real open
and honest and respectful conversation
that really influences
how each of us think
about this topic in our own lives and also
how we think about this topic in the lives
of those around us.
So with that introduction,
that little bit of background,
it's my pleasure to introduce
to the stage Lecrae.
(audience applauding)
- How does this mic reach? Okay. Good.
(audience laughs)
Height situation going on here.
Well, it's an honor to be here.
I'm really just, again,
blown away at everything
that I've experienced
since I've been here.
I came here a few years
back and I'm glad to be back
on the campus.
Anita, that was amazing.
First of all, I don't even know
where you are. There you go.
Listen, I don't know if
that's what Yale produces.
I need to...
(audience laughs)
Find a new option for myself here.
Well, I really believe that
if this is gonna be a sincere,
genuine conversation, that
leaders lead in vulnerability,
and in order to lead a conversation,
I have to be vulnerable,
which I think will generate
and promote more vulnerability.
I'm sure you probably,
some of you've been in
this room before or been
in rooms like it, constantly.
It may not be an environment
that you necessarily see
as conducive for like sharing and comfort,
but I just want you to imagine this place
as the most comfortable
environment that you can imagine,
one where we're just here
having a conversation.
You're not being screened.
You're not being judged.
You're not being assessed.
There's no grades being
handed out at the end
of this situation.
This is us being free to be ourselves.
And you're welcome to join in that.
And I'm also just gonna allow you to,
if you don't wanna join
the conversation to have
a window into my soul in the process.
So start a little bit about me.
I'm just gonna get right into it.
I, as we're talking about
this intersection of faith,
mental health, social justice,
I'm gonna start with the dark seasons
that I've experienced in life,
because I think that contributes to all
of those particular issues.
So for me, let me set a timer,
because I can talk, all right?
And we will not get
anything else accomplished
in here today.
But for me, I actually
recall the dark seasons
of my life starting as
old as age seven, right?
So seven years old,
I was invited into the room
of a close family member
and I was taken advantage of sexually.
And so here I am seven
years old and I have to now
wear these scars on the playground, right?
I gotta wear these scars amongst my peers,
as they are playing
four square or whatnot.
I have to wear these
scars on Saturday morning
when I'm watching my cartoons.
I have to wear these scars of this abuse
in environments with
the exact person who put
these scars on me and act
as if nothing happened,
because it wasn't dealt
with, it wasn't handled.
So I learned something in that situation,
something very unhealthy.
And what I learned was to
suppress trauma and pretend
as if nothing happened
and just plow through.
That was the first unhealthy
lesson I learned as far
as trauma was concerned was
to just, hey, box that up,
keep it moving forward.
If you wanna add to that,
I grew up in an environment and a home
that was very unhealthy.
It was not a healthy environment.
It was filled with immaturity. Drugs.
It was filled with just
so many different nuances
that made it difficult
for me to have a healthy
outlook on life.
Four years old, my father was gone.
I never saw him again
until 25 years later.
So you add to that,
I was learning in that
environment of who I was
supposed to be from the
models in my community.
And so what that led to
is a young man who had
experienced everything,
from physical abuse, drugs,
as I said before, sexual abuse.
And now I was not just the
recipient of these things.
I was starting to take
on these characteristics
and flesh them out on a day-to-day basis
to where the police were coming
to my house consistently.
I found myself consistently
depressed and in a messed
up state of being, this is
all before the age of 18.
But I remember as a kid, people saying,
you remind me of your father.
You act like your father.
You're just like your father.
You're similar to your father.
And I didn't take it as a compliment,
even if it was just a mere observation.
I took it as an insult,
because this was a man
that wasn't consistent.
This was a man that had
taken on drug abuse.
And probably has a lot of
mental health issues himself.
But I saw that as an example
of who I should not be.
And so what I did at
that point in time was
consumed myself with not being my father.
I didn't consume myself with figuring
out who I was supposed to be.
I consumed myself with not
being this example of a person.
So I took that initiative.
But the problem in me trying
so hard to not be him was
I didn't know who I was supposed to be.
And on top of that,
all the trauma that I had experienced
throughout this period of time,
I was just stuffing it a way,
all the pain, all the abuse,
all of those particular things.
I was stuffing it away because
I had an agenda and I had
a mission and that was
to not be my father.
And so, externally, I
was succeeding, right?
Externally I'm succeeding.
I got scholarships.
I went to college, I made the Dean's list.
I graduated, I interned, I
got a good corporate job,
after corporate job I started a business,
a successful business at that,
but internally I was headed for disaster.
So externally I'm succeeding,
but internally I'm failing tremendously,
but I don't even realize it.
I learned to take the
worst circumstances of life
and push them deep down
into this internal closet.
And I'm bleeding internally,
but I'm thinking I'm okay.
And if you have a vital
wound and you ignore it,
it doesn't get better.
It eventually kills you.
So I'm moving a million miles an hour.
Now there's a marriage.
There's three kids.
It's running multiple businesses.
The successful music
career. I'm winning Grammys.
New York times bestselling author.
And then it all came to a head.
In front of the world I was
just level-headed God-fearing man.
I'm navigating everything
just the way that I should.
But behind the scenes,
I'm a ticking time bomb,
ignoring all of the trauma,
ignoring all of the weight
of these experiences
and this depression that is
knocking at my front door.
And it was during this time,
I remember watching a
video of a young man,
probably about 15 years old
in Chicago, and he's waving
a gun around and flaunting it.
And I remember something
being triggered, right?
It moved me almost to tears.
I learned about the facts of
the murder rate in Chicago.
And I was, and I found myself sitting
there emotionally just devastated.
And I couldn't understand why.
Well, truthfully, I had
a friend who was taken
by gun violence at age 13 years old,
and that trauma was triggered.
I didn't even realize it.
I was the victim of this,
witnessing a death of a teenager.
And then I'm seeing this
other teenager just flaunting.
And I didn't even connect those dots.
Later that year, I remember
hearing about the death
of Trayvon Martin.
Now, I was affected, right?
I'm affected by this murder.
I'm affected by what's happened
to Trayvon, but I didn't
know how to express it.
I didn't know what avenues or
venues I had to express it.
And so once again,
the same thing I had learned
previously to take trauma,
to take traumatizing
experiences and stuff them
away is what I practiced.
So I'm disturbed to the
core. I'm fueled with anger.
I remember as a kid
seeing my mother fueled
with anger and frustration
after Rodney King was
beaten down and her hearing
the verdict and all these
particular things happened,
but I don't know how to navigate
this particular circumstance.
And so I'm sitting in a
similar position in a couple
of years after Trayvon, it was
Renisha McBride, a young teenager who got
in a car accident and
knocked on someone's door
and was killed because she
was profiled and thought
to be committing a crime.
After Renisha McBride, there was
Eric Garner and after
Eric Garner, there was
Michael Brown and so
on and so on and Sandra
and so on and so on and so on and so on,
and then, and then, and
then there were riots.
And I found myself sitting
in the middle of all
this wondering where do I fit?
I how do I react?
I was trying to hide away
the trauma of seeing people,
who may as well have been
my cousins, my sisters,
my nieces, my aunts, being
killed, but it was overwhelming.
And I found myself in the
streets of Atlanta involved
in a protest.
So here I am protesting in this,
students from all the
surrounding colleges in the area
are protesting with me.
And all of them are
looking to me for guidance,
for wisdom, for leadership.
And I'm just as lost as they are.
I have no idea how to navigate everything
that I'm dealing with.
And at the same time, I'm this respected,
seemingly conservative artist.
And a lot of my supporters
didn't like the idea
of me getting involved in what to them was
a political affair.
What are you doing getting involved
in this political affair?
And so the dilemma that I had was dual.
It was me trying to get
involved and do something
about things that I'm seeing happening.
But then also,
I don't even know who I
am in the middle of this.
So I'm trying to find myself.
I don't know who I wanna be.
And my identity had already been forged
by finding approval in other people.
So I was losing,
my approval rate was going
down in one particular group,
as I'm trying to do
what I felt to be right.
And the trauma's weighing.
I felt what Moses, if you know anything
about Moses, Moses was Hebrew by birth,
but he was adopted by
the Egyptian aristocracy.
And it came upon him one day,
oh my goodness, I am Hebrew.
And the Hebrew people are being oppressed
by the Egyptians, but yet I'm a part
of this Egypt aristocracy.
How does this make sense? What do I do?
And so I took a page out of Moses's book,
you know what Moses did
was he killed somebody.
That's not what I did.
(audience laughs)
I tweeted.
Same-same.
I tweeted a lot, right? I'm tweeting.
But I'm saying things
outside of the boundaries
of what people expected of me,
I'm on national television after this,
I'm writing articles
after this, I'm on CNN.
And the result was this
unadulterated rejection.
So I'm despised now. I'm hated.
I've lost support regularly.
And I was about to learn
a very beautiful lesson
that stays with me to this day.
And that lesson was, if you
live for people's acceptance,
you will die from their rejection.
So I stood for something,
but it felt like I lost everything.
I worked so hard to not be
my father, to be respected,
to be successful, to be
accomplished, to be accepted,
and now I'm hated.
I mean, in days, days, y'all,
I lost hundreds of thousands
of social media followers.
It'd drive a 15 year old crazy, right?
(audience laughs)
I was bombarded with
messages of people telling me
how much respect they lost for me.
I was bombarded with hateful messages.
People sent me videos of
them burning my music,
like with fire.
(audience laughs)
At least they bought it though.
See the bright side in everything, right?
I couldn't understand how
they didn't hear my pain,
how my sorrow and my pain
that I was already taught
to suppress, and now
here I was expressing was
being pushed away.
It created a mental chaos for me.
I mean, some of it's to be expected.
We don't always wanna hear
the voices of people speak
on social or political things.
"LeBron James, stop talking
about this and just play basketball.
We don't wanna hear that from you.
We don't wanna hear the
nuance of who you are."
But still, I was at this crossroads,
this downward spiral started
to happen in my life.
And at the lowest point,
I started to get hate
messages and death threats
on myself and my family.
Racial slurs consistently pouring in,
and I was spiraling downward,
anger, depression, sadness,
frustration, a feeling of being trapped.
And I didn't know what was
real. I lost faith in people.
I lost faith in God.
I lost faith in faith.
So maybe that's not your story.
That's not why you're in this room, right?
Maybe that's not how you
came to a place of emotional,
spiritual or mental chaos.
But you do know what it feels like to have
the world sitting on your
shoulders and you feel
so lonely you wanna quit.
You do know what it
feels like to feel like
everyone's depending
on you and this pressure is overwhelming.
You do know what it feels
like for people to expect
your best, but you're
really at your worst.
But how do we navigate that?
How do we navigate that chaos?
And how do we continue
dreaming and creating?
I know I wish I could tell
you I just woke up one day
and I just found some courage.
And I just said, you
know what? I don't care.
I wish I could tell you that's the case.
I wish I could tell you I
just look deep inside myself
and I found something and pushed through.
That's not what happened.
What happened to me was
I had to open the closet.
I had to look in that closet
that I had stuffed away,
all of that trauma, all of that pain,
all of that suffering.
And I had to stare it in the
face. All of that failure.
I had to stare it in the face.
I had to look at it and allow it
to make me a new me.
I had to embrace the trauma
and allow it to mold me
into something new.
See, the shift is being
willing to die to whatever
it was that we were
before the pain to birth
the person that we're becoming.
Right, the shift is
sometimes we're too attached
to who we've been so we're
held back to who we can become.
We don't understand that there
is no triumph without trial.
We don't understand, like
working out in the gym,
you've got to fail in
order to get stronger.
It's like a foreign concept.
So I had to be willing to work and walk
through judgment and
inconvenience in order to grow,
I had to be willing to become
who I was created to be,
not who they wanted me to be.
So it's scary, right?
It's, you're standing at
the edge of something new,
you're afraid to jump and you're,
you don't know what that's
gonna, what the cost,
the opportunity cost, the cost analysis
of that situation is.
And so you're scared to jump.
I know what exactly what
it is to be scared to jump.
I was in New Zealand and I'm on
this 700 foot tower.
And they say, come on, man,
we got jump off this thing,
it's a base jump, it'll be fun.
And I was like, I don't know
if you check my skin tone any,
but this is kind of something
black people don't do.
(audience laughs)
But they convinced me, man, it'll be fun.
We should do it.
They show me a video of
Beyonce jumping off of it.
(audience laughs)
But see, there's a million
things Beyonce can do
that I can't so that's
not really a good...
So I get up there and I'm
telling myself, let's do it.
And I look down and I see
Tupac and Michael Jackson
waving at me.
(audience laughs)
And I say, I'm not gonna be able to jump.
I can't do this.
And they said, fine,
can you move out the way so
this 11 year old girl can jump?
(audience laughs)
So then I had to jump. But
I'm better because of it.
I wouldn't even be able
to tell you the story had
I not taken that jump.
We're so afraid to jump
because we're so focused
on how far the fall is.
We're so focused on what the failure
of that jump looks like.
And we have to become something new.
We have to take our traumas
and allow them to make us
a part of who we wanna be.
Take the terrible events
and create a story
of triumph, right?
Athletes don't quit at the
toughest part of the game,
that's when they wanna
play harder, dream higher,
push further, become something new.
You don't despise the caterpillar.
You don't despise the cocoon that turns
a caterpillar into a butterfly, right?
It doesn't make sense.
And so sometimes recognizing
and realizing, you know what?
I'm broken and there's
some issues in my life
that I need to address, I need
to face, I need to look at,
I need to talk about,
is the only way to get to
the other side of them.
And had I not addressed them,
had I not looked in the closet,
had I not stared in the face
of these particular things?
I wouldn't have seen what
I believe God was trying
to do was make me into a
better version of myself,
was build me into something else.
And so I own my story.
And that's what we've gotta,
we've gotta own our story.
I had to own my story and
say, this is who I am,
this is what made me who I am,
this is a part of my
journey and because of that,
I am who I am.
The strength that I have
is because of what I've gone through.
These are our scars, right?
We show people our scars to
prove that healing is real.
If no one shows you their scars,
you walk around believing like, oh,
there's no coming back from that.
But then here are real
life people saying, no,
I have these same scars,
I survived and I'm
stronger and so are you,
but first you've gotta
admit that you're wounded.
I could tell a million stories.
One story that comes to mind is Raison.
Raison Harris, who is incarcerated
at San Quentin and Raison was incarcerated
because he took a man's
life and he's doing 55
years to life.
When he went into prison, he
was depressed. He was angry.
He was bitter.
He was frustrated because
he made a decision
as a youngster that is now
affected the rest of his life.
But after a few years,
he said, you know what?
I'm not going to allow
this circumstance to change
my outlook on life.
I'm going to use this
time to become a better
version of myself.
So he took financial literacy classes.
He took writing classes.
He became a writer
for the San Quentin
Newspaper, which is the only
inmate operated and run
newspaper in existence,
his writings and his stories
now appear in Vice, in GQ.
And if the Board and the
Governor and God are on his side,
which I believe they are, he's
going to walk out, paroled,
with a career in journalism
and stock investments
from all the years he was
investing while he was locked up.
And so had he sat in it and just said, oh,
this is my fate in life,
it would have been a terrible situation,
but because he said, you know what,
I'm gonna let this mold
me into something new,
I'm gonna own this, I'm gonna admit this,
I'm in a bad state and
I'm gonna acknowledge
it and figure out how I can work
through this is the only way
to come out on the other side.
And so I'll say this. That's
where my plane landed.
My plane landed with me
acknowledging I'm broken,
acknowledging I'm not perfect,
acknowledging I don't get it all right,
acknowledging I have a
lot of wounds that are now
healed and have become scars.
And I can stand here today
and show you my scars,
because those wounds have healed.
But you've gotta admit it, right?
And so that has restored
my faith in faith.
That has restored my faith
in God, because God is
the healer of all things
and my wounds are healed because of him.
And I was fighting so hard
to not be my father, right?
I'm fighting so hard to not be my father,
I didn't realize who I was supposed to be.
So a I'm at track meet for my son.
My oldest son is 10 years old.
He's running track and track
meets are extremely boring.
They're long and hot.
His first has been at eight in the morning
and the second one,
they don't even tell you
when it is and it's at three.
So you just sit in there,
like, when is it gonna come in?
And I'm there were my five-year-old
and my five-year-old is
bored out of his mind.
So I'm trying to keep his attention.
And I say, hey, what do you
wanna do with your life?
(audience laughs)
I thought that was appropriate.
I was trying. I mean,
he's struggling, right?
Like he's struggling,
like ah, ah, the weight
of the world on his
five-year-old shoulders.
And he says, "Daddy, I don't know,
I just wanna be like you."
And listen, I would not be
the me he wants to be like,
had I not owned my past
and present circumstances,
failures, situations and
allowed it to mold me
into the me that I am today.
There wouldn't be a me
he aspires to be had
I not owned that.
So I say to you all,
I'm grateful for the
opportunity to show my scars,
to admit my brokenness and
to allow that to continue
to make me into a better
version of myself.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
That's my line, do good.
(audience laughs)
- Well, thanks again to Lecrae
for that openness and that vulnerability.
And just the way he's really been vocal
about speaking about these
social justice issues
and also being vulnerable
about the mental health
aspect and still being
bold about this space.
We definitely appreciate you.
So at this point,
we're gonna shift in the
program to more of the town
hall piece of things.
But before we do that,
I did want to acknowledge
all of our sponsors
for tonight's event, which
I forgot to do earlier.
Definitely important piece.
So one of the sponsors
is Yale Well, that's been
very integral in sponsoring this event,
also The Office of the
Secretary and Vice President
for Student Life,
particularly Kimberly Goff-Crews
who's here in the front.
So thank you for it to you
for your sponsorship as well.
A round of applause.
(audience applauding)
Also the Chaplain's Office and
Sharon Kugler in particular,
also again, The Black Church
at Yale, and my laboratory,
specifically Eric Nunes and Durga Rathi
who've been also integrally involved
in supporting this as well.
So with that, I'd like
to invite Lecrae back up
to the stage and Pastor OrLando.
We're gonna go into a little bit
of a Q&A, and this is definitely
an opportunity for all
of you to interact and be involved.
So we definitely want
this to be a conversation,
especially with what Lecrae
has just brought forth to us,
to really have a conversation
amongst us, it's really,
start to, again,
begin some of these
important conversations,
which I'm sure some of you already had,
but to continue those
and continue those beyond
tonight as well.
So I invite Pastor OrLando,
Lecrae back up to the stage.
- Okay. So yeah, I'm
representing the black church.
So this is gonna be
interactive, all right.
But I just thank all those
who helped get us started
in this conversation.
I do recognize that this
is a ongoing conversation,
that we're not launching it,
but we're just helping
it to continue to move.
A question for you.
What did you hear in the
talk and the presentation?
What's themes, struggles,
joys stood out to you?
What did you hear? What do
you wanna know more about?
If you can just take a
minute and think about that.
For some of you who wanna write it down,
please take an index
card and write it down.
What stood out to you?
What stands out to you?
And what do you wanna hear more about?
If you need an index card,
there are people who can
hand it to you or a pen,
people who can hand it to you.
Okay. And this is a real
black church experience.
Turn into your neighbor.
(audience laughs)
Turn to a person next to you.
If you don't know them,
introduce yourself.
Hi, my name is...
(audience murmurs)
Take a minute and share your thought.
What is it that you
want to know more about?
What is standing out to
you? Speak to each other?
I have a question that
I want to pose to you.
Pose to Lecrae.
In designing our time together,
there were a number of
you who gave insight
and feedback in terms of
what was important to you.
What resonates with those around you.
What resonates on this campus.
And we've taken some of
those questions and I'll ask
some of them now.
And I recognize there
are many more questions.
So one question and,
Lecrae, you can decide whether
you wanna answer first.
Then I'll ask you four of you.
Four of you here to respond.
What are your biggest
challenges to maintaining
a healthy mental state?
What are effective
practices for maintaining
a healthy mental state?
So what are your biggest
challenges to maintaining
a healthy mental state?
What are the effective practices
for you for maintaining
a healthy mental state?
Are you gonna go first or pass?
- Oh yeah.
You are taking the microphone
from a rapper, come on, man.
(audience laughs)
Again, the biggest thing that I want
to acknowledge is that you
have to recognize you need
a healthy mental state, right?
And if you think you can
just plow through life
without investigating,
it's like driving a car
and never looking under the
hood or getting it checked out,
or just thinking everything
will be fine for life.
And I'm sure there's some people who do
that now, not smart.
So that was the biggest thing for me was
to acknowledge that
even if I feel like I'm able
to accomplish the things
that I'm able to do
on a regular basis, maybe
I'm not healthy here.
And so it's been going to
see counselors or therapy.
And to me,
counselors is going to get
a checkup on my car, right?
It's like going to the, just the physical,
it's taking care of myself.
So that was step one, I think, for me,
and then the continual practice,
is now I have language or
playing field to understand,
because I'm talking to
someone who is trained
in this particular area.
So now I have language and
practice to do some self care.
And self care for me, I was
talking about this earlier,
is understanding that I need time
to not be busy.
I think busyness, in many ways means,
your life is out of control.
You don't have control over
it 'cause you're so busy.
So I need time.
I say I do DWA, that's a daily diversion,
a weekly withdrawal,
and an annual abandon.
And so daily diversion is
just, even if it's an hour,
just daily, where I can, if
I use my mind all the time,
let me use my hands,
let me go play with Play-Doh
or color or do something.
You know what I mean?
With my, to where I'm just
diverted from all the things
I have going on.
A weekly withdrawal is just
taking a day weekly and saying,
I'm gonna stop.
I'm gonna pause.
I'm gonna do something
that has nothing to do
with the things that are stressing me out.
And then an annual abandon
is just taking some
time every year to get away from it all.
And that's, that's me,
you know what I mean?
So that's not necessarily the
prescription for everyone,
because everyone has
different issues going on,
but that's how I'm taking care of myself.
- Yeah. Thank you.
There are four of you who would...
Yes.
- [Audience Member] Hi, thank
you so much for sharing.
How did, you mentioned God
some, how did God help you?
And, I actually find it so interesting,
how we're from different cultures,
but I feel so much that you
feel, and I related so much,
that this is my struggle
right now is walking
in spirit and flesh at the same time.
And it's such a struggle.
I just talked to people today about that.
And I was wondering if you
had what you do to do that.
It seems the closer I get
to God, the more the dark
side comes up.
I think it's, that's one question anyway.
And do you believe like
in spiritual deliverance
and things like that, like
if you'd gotten any prayer,
'cause I know that there's
a lot of spiritual bondage
when you get into the abuse and the way
that you've lived in
abandonment, you mentioned...
What was the word you used?
When you were, the trauma
from when your dad left,
there was abandonment
and something else...
Anyway, I'm just
wondering what you thought
about that because I'm
very involved in church
and I do understand that there's
a lot of spiritual bondage
and wondering what you thought about that.
- You.
- Great question.
So yes, part of it,
for me, was understanding,
healing is a process, right?
So it's a continual process.
And I tried to think of a time
in my life where God just,
he didn't come through and I
couldn't think of one, right?
So that was part of the process
was saying he's dependable.
So let me trust him in this
particular circumstance.
And then there's so many
different examples, like,
as I looked at Job and looked at his life
and as I looked at
Lamentations and just looked
at Moses and it's like,
he's not gonna, Joshua,
he's not gonna take you all the way
through the wilderness to
the edge of the promised
land and then say, "Bye!"
Right?
So it's like, there's a
process of coming through all
of that in order to get to this place.
And that process involves trust.
And for me, it was him
inviting me to trust him
in the midst of that madness.
I think personally, it
was very helpful for me
because I tend to wear all of the burden
on my own shoulders.
It was helpful for me
to know that God wants
to carry those burdens.
It was helpful for me
to know that he wants me
dependent and broken and not
perfect and put together.
And so I could relinquish a lot
of this that I had weighing
on me in his hands.
And I know that sounds a
ethereal, just out there,
but part of it was for
me looking in the text,
looking at scriptures and
seeing promises and seeing
these realities flesh themselves
out and stop trying to be,
or not be my earthly father and focus
on my heavenly father, you know?
And that was a big piece of it for me.
- [Audience Member] Rejection. What else?
Abandonment and rejection.
- Rejection. Yeah.
I'm accepted.
So that was the biggest piece
too, is I'm accepted, right?
Like if I, if I'm accepted by
the creator of all creation,
why am I fighting for
everyone else's acceptance?
Doesn't make sense, right?
- Thank you.
Someone else?
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
How to bring up a child
from the age of one week,
show that the child
will be confident, kind,
in contrast to being spoiled
by getting a gold star
for doing nothing.
- Participation trophies,
I take it you're not a fan of those.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, I mean. Again, so let me say this.
- And how are you doing this?
- Yeah. So let me say this.
So another thing I
talked about earlier was
it's very important for
me to be healthy if I want
to create health in my family.
It's very important for me
to have a proper perspective
of who I am and to have.
A lot of the areas of my
mental health and trauma
were identity issues.
I didn't know who I was.
I didn't know who I was created to be.
And so success was always
me comparing myself
to other people, instead
of comparing myself
to what I was supposed to do,
to what I had a vision to accomplish.
It had really nothing to do
with everyone else around me.
It should have had more to do
with the vision that I had.
And so for me it's important to have,
to take proper care of myself first,
before I take care of my kids.
Because if I'm not healthy,
I have nothing to offer them.
And then you will tend
to, put it like this,
if you have what I would
call like functional saviors
or scapegoats to deal
with your issues in life,
you're going to reimplement
that for your children.
So if you think money will
solve all of your problems,
then you're gonna teach your
children the same thing.
And they're gonna think
that there's some kind
of crutch can lean on.
I stopped rewarding my
children with desserts
and things along those
lines when they do well.
And the reason why is
because I didn't want them
to feel like eating
unhealthy was how they should
reward themselves in life.
Right?
Because then that, and I, so
it's like, oh, you're sad?
Come on, let's go get a cheeseburger.
I mean, cheer you up
with an ice cream cone,
because then what does that
teach them down the road?
Like, well, I'm sad,
I'm gonna eat this whole chocolate cake,
because that's what...
(audience laughs)
Right? So, but I have to
know that about myself first.
And so a lot of it has
been me having to learn
these particular things.
- Thank you. The mic runners
are in charge. (laughs)
I see multiple hands. There's
one here in the front.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you so much for your talk
and your vulnerability.
I'm wondering how you use your trauma
and or what your experience
with mental health in your art,
in, and I'm wondering if
you do use it, if you,
'cause I'm wondering about
the idea of expressing
yourself as a holistic person,
just if you could talk about that.
- Yeah. I think that's good.
I think expression,
specifically like in art,
is a part of owning your narrative, right?
And when you can own your narrative,
it's no longer a tool of
oppression against you.
It's a tool of empowerment, right?
So I can own my narrative and I own it.
It's the, one of the most
amazing things Eminem ever did,
way back when, was when
he wrote "Lose Yourself".
And he did the whole "8 Mile" movie,
he cut his own legs off.
He acknowledged his own weaknesses
before anyone else could.
And for me, art has been a
place to acknowledge openly
my weaknesses, acknowledge my struggles.
Now, sometimes I'm
acknowledging them for myself,
not for the world to hear,
but specifically when
there's weaknesses or issues
that I have processed and I have gone
through and I've gotten help with,
and I have been counseled through,
I don't mind talking about those publicly
because I'm on the other side of it.
And they're not,
they're not stories for me to be
ashamed of, they're stories
that I triumphed through,
and have made me a
better version of myself.
And so art is,
it has been very therapeutic
for me in that regard
because I can talk about
it and I can express it.
I don't think every piece of
art needs to be heard or seen,
but they need to be created for sure.
Yeah.
- There's a student here.
- [Audience Member] Oh,
okay. So I have a question.
How would you necessarily
respond to someone?
Say like in the church who
says like mental illness
doesn't exist, just pray about it,
God's gonna handle it and
just leave it at that.
And then my second question is how do
you view like suicide?
And in church, I can't
remember the pastor's name,
but more recently in the media,
there was a pastor who died
by suicide and it's been
like more so on the
forefront with the church.
And people saying like, by him doing that,
he was selfish and condemning him.
And like, God doesn't like that.
Like how would you respond to like
the criticisms like that?
- Yeah.
I'm very sensitive,
specifically when I think we say
the church and I think
there's this homogenistic
kind of perspective of what that means.
And so it's easy to, like, say,
this is what The Church thinks.
The church is not a homogeny,
there's individuals
within that have unique
perspectives on things.
And some of them you vehemently
disagree with and some
you love and you do agree with.
And so as it pertains to
like what the church says
about mental health, I don't know.
I know that the church
that I interact with sees
it as necessary, sees it
as very beneficial to seek
self care and counsel and
therapy and whatever's necessary.
And so I can speak on behalf
of those group of people.
Those who would say that, I would say,
tell them to stop going
to bed every night then.
'Cause if you just need to pray
about it, then don't sleep.
Just pray about it. You
don't need to sleep.
Why are you sleeping? Just pray about it.
God will deliver you and you can make it,
you know what I mean?
It's like, it's just...
So we're here as
crooked sticks drawing
straight lines, right?
And so we're not here to
be perfect androids, right?
We're here as examples of
what a great God can do
with broken people.
And I think that's the difference there.
And so, and that,
I think that carries over
into criminal activity,
that carries over into depression,
that carries over into
all of those particular
issues, suicide included.
That that's evidence of
broken, hurting people, right?
It's not that...
There's no reason to cast judgment,
to throw stones in that
particular circumstance.
That's just the evidence
of broken people that God
still uses in different
ways that are beyond
our comprehension at times.
So, my perspective.
- So additional questions
that some of you submitted
ahead of time, just to know
that there're more questions.
What are some of the
barriers that prevent people
from seeking out mental health services?
What is the current state of mental health
conversations in our society,
on college campuses at Yale?
How do you kind of have an
effective work-life balance?
I wanna give us another
opportunity to interact
with your neighbor,
the person next to you.
First, take a minute
and think in the realm
of social justice, what
are some of the positive
changes that you've tried
to make in your life
or the life of those
around you in the midst
of ongoing social justice challenges?
So what are some of the positive changes
that you've tried to make
in your life or the lives
of those around you in
the midst of ongoing
social justice challenges?
So give me about 10 minutes just to think
about it or 10 seconds to think about it.
10 minutes is a long time, right?
- Yale people, think!
(audience laughs)
- And when you're ready, you know,
share it with the person next to you,
have a conversation with
the person next to you,
and then we'll come back to additional
questions and comments.
This is good. This is good.
Excellent. This is good.
Hopefully you weren't talking
about what's in the dining hall,
but you were actually in
conversation about what,
what's the importance to you.
If you would go ahead and share?
- Yeah. So social justice...
And there's many facets of it, right?
And I've been involved in a
number of different facets
of what we would say social justice is.
It's made me a better
person in a multitude
of different ways.
So on one, point one,
it's made me stop seeing
myself as a commodity,
being able to be bought,
because there's a sacrifice
that I had to make financially,
commercially, whatever you would call it,
to say things that weren't
palatable for parts of society.
And it's easy to just kind
of try to toe the line
and walk the fence in order to secure.
It showed, I mean,
it exposed parts of my heart that were
just financially motivated.
And I'm not saying we
shouldn't be responsible,
but I'm saying we should care.
And so I would go from doing
a show for 3,000 people.
And then as I started to
raise my voice on issues
of police brutality, those
shows shrink dramatically.
And so did my account. But it freed me.
It freed me to be myself.
Another way that it made me
better was, it made me very...
Because of the issues that I
saw happening in my community,
specifically the black community,
it made me more attuned
to other communities.
And so then I had to ask
myself, how misogynistic,
how patriarchal am I?
And how can I care about
these issues of black people,
but not care about the issues of women?
Right?
And so I had to start
digging more and growing
in multitude of different
other areas, other ethnicities,
and begin to care about it
as a global issue as well.
- Thank you. Are there four
of us who can contribute?
So there is a hand here. Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Hi.
Speaking about community, I was just,
I just wanted to know what is the role
that a community can play
in the healing process
and in addressing mental health issues,
specifically to you, in your experience,
did you have a community with
which to channel, to talk,
to consult, to go through
what you're going through.
And my second question is,
how do we as Yale students
from where the communities,
where we come from?
Like, for example, I
come from South Africa.
So how do I go back and
like create dialogue
in the community where I've come from,
and particularly in
marginalized communities.
So where like people
feel that seemingly more
pressing issues than mental
health, for example, poverty,
unemployment, drugs, you
know, those are seemingly,
at least people feel that
they are urgent and important
than actually mental health.
So how do we create a
work in such a community?
How do you create conversations
and how do we bring
about that intersection?
So how do you bring the faith community
to that conversation?
How do you bring the
culture to that community
and also social justice as well.
So those are two questions.
Basically I have your personal
journey with community
and also how do we create
these conversations
in the communities where we come from?
- I should be brief,
'cause I noticed a lot of
other comments as well.
Where in South Africa are you from?
- [Audience Member]
I'm from Port Elizabeth
but came to as like my second home.
- Right on, I just got
back from South Africa.
So shout out to you. Congratulations.
You made it.
So, on question two,
you talked about how to you
lead in those particular.
I think leaders lead in
vulnerability, right?
So you've got to be the
vulnerable one and show
the example of how
you're still here,
irregardless of the
scrutiny or whatever you may
have faced for being honest
about issues of mental health,
issues of societal
injustice, social injustice,
you addressed it, you lived through it,
you still got all your
limbs and you're sitting
at Yale University, right?
So I think you are a living
breathing example for a lot
of people, specifically in
those marginalized communities,
that it can be done.
You give them the freedom,
you give them the power to do
that, to the first question,
community is everything, if
you don't have a community
to express these particular things with,
then you begin to build it.
And sometimes, I know for
me, building community,
I had to let my guard down with people
that I might've otherwise disagreed
with in my more arrogant self contained,
self sufficient, self
sustaining version of myself,
the more dependent version
of the person that said,
you know what?
I don't know everything, I
don't have it all figured out,
made relationships across the divide.
And so now I'm having
conversations with a young lady
who I would not have agreed
with on certain things,
but I do agree with her on mental health
or the issues of womanhood.
And now I'm like, well, what
else can I learn from her?
I wouldn't have otherwise,
if I had not had a conversation
with her because I disagreed so vehemently
on these particular things.
And now we're dialoguing more
and we're becoming good friends.
And I think that's happened
very consistently for me.
And I think that's a part
of what happens as well.
But so yes.
- [Audience Member] So
I have bipolar disorder
and I've had a really great
fortune to have medication
and therapy, and I'm also
a songwriter and I've been
able to use music to
process a lot of that.
And my faith has also been
a very instrumental part
of my recovery.
I'm also in a band with
a couple other people
who also have bipolar disorder.
- Yeah!
(audience member laughs)
- [Audience Member] And
so of a lot our songs are
about mental health, about recovery,
about healing from abuse and trauma,
recovery from addiction.
And even with the help,
I've had moments and experiences
of just really being baffled.
I had to resign from my
job teaching to take care
of my mental health.
And through that, I also had
a profound sense that God
was working through my
mental illness to bring me
in closer relationship with him,
to bring me into my own purpose
and my, like as you were saying,
sort of a truer version of myself.
And so my question sometimes
when I'm experiencing something,
is this God, or is this bipolar?
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] Exactly. Yeah.
And that's been my answer.
It's often God working
through my mental illness.
And my question is,
how can we help people
navigate those spaces?
I've talked to a lot of
people who don't really have
a framework or a language to talk
about God and mental
illness in the same steps
or in the same conversation.
People who, at church,
don't hear much about,
they might not hear a
lot about mental illness.
And then in mental health settings,
not hearing much about God.
So I'm wondering if there
are ways we can help
people integrate the two?
I think this conversation
here is a great example
of one way,
and I'm wondering what
other ways might look like.
- That's great. More power to you.
Love you. Thank you for
your vulnerability too.
So, long way to answer this question.
I was in Paris and I was so
excited about being in Paris.
It was like, dreams, romantic city.
I can't wait to see everything
and talk to these people.
It's gonna be great. The
food is gonna be amazing.
And then I got to Paris and I
couldn't understand anything.
And no one would accommodate
my American privilege
and speak English to me.
(audience laughs)
And I struggled and I hated it.
And I couldn't read the
menus and I couldn't
understand where I was going.
And no one would explain to me anything.
And I was just so
disappointed and frustrated.
I just opted to eat at
McDonald's because I was tired.
Right?
But I have a friend of mine who's been
there for a year now.
And he said, I felt the same way you did.
But then I wrestled through
all of the complexity
of it and saw the beauty
in the complexity and now
I love Paris.
And I say that to say
this, that many times,
especially in the faith community,
we, and just in general,
we struggle with the nuance.
We struggle with
complexity. We love it easy.
And there's beauty in complexity
in wrestling with nuance.
And in many times we're
creating new categories
for people that they just aren't...
"Argh! What?
Mental health, faith, ah, it's too much.
I can't do it."
But this is evidence that
that's a category that needs
to be walked through,
and it's often difficult and frustrating,
but when you get to the
other side, it's worth it.
And so, and I've seen
that time and time again
in my life that I'm constantly
creating new categories
and breaking barriers that
people just didn't think
could exist, but then
people get to see the beauty
of it once they get on the other side.
So this is that as you're talking about,
and I think it's continuing this,
even though it's difficult and ugly,
continue pushing through
to create new categories
and wrestle with nuance
and seeing the beauty
in the complexity.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So you
previously talked about how,
as you got more involved
in social justice,
you experienced this rejection,
and I know previously you've
talked about how you had
to break up with white evangelicalism.
And I know that for me, personally,
that breakup has been
freeing and so liberating
in many ways and has, I think,
rejuvenated my faith and my
call to ministry in many ways.
So I'm interested to know
what that breakup did
for you and how that has
kind of helped you to regain
that faith in God and
your mental wellbeing?
- Yeah, I think, when,
in the podcast, you know,
it was suggested, "It
sounds like you've broken up
with white evangelicalism."
And for me, even though
I was still processing
in that moment, but what
that meant and what it means
for me more than anything is not believing
that there's one sect of my faith.
One group of people within that
has all the answers. Right?
And I think I just stayed
on one trek and kept
reading only the people's
books on this trek.
And I didn't even read these
books because they said
all the negative things
about these authors.
And so I never knew what was
wrong about these authors.
I never understood what was right.
And I never realized or assumed or came
to the conclusion that, wait,
this trek could be wrong, right?
Like there's things wrong here that are
not being acknowledged.
And so for me, that was,
it was more about saying
I'm not excluding myself
from these perspectives
globally, historically,
that had just aren't talked about, right?
Usually when we talk about church history,
for whatever reason, it jumps straight
from Israel to Europe.
And I don't, for me,
I'm like, wait a minute.
What about the Ethiopian that left,
and where's the church, hey,
you know, Asia has a church,
the Middle East, the
Syriacs, the Coptics and none
of that stuff's ever mentioned.
And that's what helped
me realize it's a very
Eurocentric colonized view
on Christianity that I was embracing.
And I said, I'm not gonna do that.
I'm going to see it globally.
And that means there's
gonna be perspectives
that are gonna fight against each other
but that's okay because I
think God likes us to not
have all the answers.
And when any camp says
they have all the answers,
that's the camp you might
wanna stay away from.
Just saying.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you so much, Lecrae.
And I just wanted to actually respond
to the previous comment
about other settings
of the intersection of
mental health and faith.
And so, even, I can
speak for myself as well
as a mental health provider.
And there are several in
the room as well who are
people of faith, and
from personal experience,
it's something that
incorporate in the clinic
practice with my patients,
I've even prayed with my patients as well.
And so there are people who
will be open about that,
not with every patient,
but there are times where I
may feel led to discuss that.
And I feel that people can be receptive,
because they're looking for like
the bio-psycho-social-spiritual,
that aspect.
And many people also use
their faith as a coping
mechanism, coping strategy.
And so I think that that's also important.
And I also try to
incorporate that as well.
So that's another venue.
And as I mentioned,
there are several people
in this room who are
mental health providers
of faith, who practice,
who are a Christian.
- Thank you. Thank you.
And thank you. Keep going.
Buy some copies of my man's
bipolar band, send 'em out.
(audience laughs)
Just before, stream
that, we'll stream that.
- I really appreciate the conversation.
And so this is another
opportunity to interact
with your neighbor.
And instead of me posing
a question, it's time,
that comment that you
have, that you wanna say,
please turn to your neighbor
and share that comment,
share that insight, just
coming up for you now,
what you're thinking about,
what you're holding on to
that is either a struggle
or maybe a big win for you in this moment.
Please turn to a person
next to you and share.
Please leave no one out in sharing.
(audience murmurs)
Okay.
We'll come back together.
And I wanna ask Lecrae this
final question that I have,
and also open it up to
four of you to share.
Looking at culture, how do culture,
cultural background and
cultural perspectives
influence your view of yourself
and how you interact in society?
So how do culture,
cultural background and
cultural perspectives
influence your view of yourself
and how you interact with society?
- Wow. Phew.
When I speak on this, I'm
speaking as a journeyer,
someone who's on the journey,
not someone who's reached
the pinnacle and has
the solutions, right?
So as I speak about it, I'm not speaking,
I'm speaking as an expert from experience,
not an expert from like, oh,
I've researched this and
I have the answers, right?
So, but in my experience,
similar to what my friend here was talking
about in terms of God
using his being bipolar,
I think my cultural experiences have been,
though detrimental and painful,
have been used to shape
a lot of who I am now.
And it's been me not being
ashamed of them, but to say, no,
this is a part of my narrative.
And narrative is, no one,
we all learn from narrative,
right? We love narrative.
We learned from story,
especially stories of trial and triumph.
And so no one wants to go to
a "Lord of the Rings" film
and just see there a kid
who lost his way and found
the ring and thought the
ring was a part of himself,
but it wasn't, and then he
found himself and now the end.
Like we wanna see the
whole thing play out.
And I think we forget
that we're in a narrative,
where our narrative is being written.
We're a part of a grand narrative.
And so I feel like culture, in many ways,
shapes our views on the world,
and that's why we can
oftentimes need to come
together with other cultures to like,
have a complete perspective.
And sometimes it's negative and sometimes
it has its benefits.
I don't think it's all, like,
I can't look at how I
came up or what I came
through and think it
is the best or the way.
And I think that's where the danger lies.
So another analogy I use,
I use analogies often
to drive my wife crazy,
but it's how I communicate,
is if I'm at a baseball game,
I hate baseball by the way,
but if I was to be at a baseball game,
if I'm sitting outfield watching the game,
I would think I have a great
perspective of the game,
but then someone's sitting
behind the batter would say, no,
I have a great perspective
of the whole game.
And meanwhile, the pitcher
saying, no, I'm in the game.
I have a great perspective of the game.
And I think the reality is every one
of those particular people
have a vantage point,
but it's the collective that is
helpful for them to see where they lack
and to see what other people don't see.
And I think that's what for me,
my culture has helped me
to see things that other
people don't see.
So when people say oh
the Black Panthers is a
terrorist group, I say, ah,
they fed my mother as a
child when she was starving.
So various perspectives. So yeah.
- Thank you. Thank you.
Who would like to share?
Oh, you have a mic...
- [Audience Member] I have a
question. It's actually, yeah.
My question really just has to do with,
you mentioned that like you like joined
these movements and suddenly like,
all these ratings are going
down and all this tracks,
and then you put forward, like,
I'll find you the track saying that,
it's lit by the way.
Like, I'm such a huge, I don't get music,
but my question is,
how then did you bring
yourself around to learn
to trust people again, and
to learn to love again?
Because you mentioned how important, like,
the approval of people was for you.
So going through that period of rejection,
how do you love people authentically
even after what they've done to you?
Oh yeah.
- Oh, that's good. That's a
really good, that took time.
I'm not gonna lie to
you that it took time.
It's, it was a season of just like,
you know, yeah,
just certain authors,
my stomach, I'll throw
that book in the trash.
You know what I mean?
Just, but part of it is,
as you mentioned, like,
"I'll Find You", "I'll Find
You" is the biggest song
I've ever put out in my career,
in the darkest time of my life.
And I think that's part of the lesson,
that God said, well, good.
You saw my acceptance, not other people's.
And look what did in that process, right?
Oh, you were fighting for acceptance.
You hit a ceiling,
but when you stopped
fighting for acceptance
and just were authentically yourself,
look at what happened.
And people are drawn
to authenticity anyway.
So you liberated a lot more
people than you would've
ever met, just so that was part one.
And then trusting and loving people again,
it's just really hard to be hopeful
and hateful at the same time.
Right? It's really hard
to be hopeful and hateful.
And so, as my hope increased,
my love increased for other people,
because as I have a hope in and of myself,
it's just really hard for
me to just look at someone
else and say, "They just make me sick."
Right? You know?
So the trust was a process.
It didn't happen overnight,
but as I took time for
self care to grow...
I found more security. I
understood myself more.
I filled in some gaps, right?
In my own understanding
about faith, about...
I read a lot of books
from all over the world
from different authors that
I wouldn't have otherwise
read and gaps got filled in.
And then I was hopeful and I
was like, oh, this is great.
It's like, well, I'm not
mad at y'all no more,
I feel bad for y'all,
'cause I know things that y'all don't.
It's pretty bad.
Y'all don't know this,
you know what I mean?
And so it was a process.
If you didn't hear her,
she was asking for strategies
to fight what feels like
a continual state of brokenness.
And my youngest son
was a very, very pitiful child.
I mean, just being honest,
he couldn't dress himself.
He used the bathroom
on himself constantly.
He couldn't feed himself,
just really pitiful.
It was sad, man.
And, but I wasn't frustrated
at him, because he was my son.
And because even though
performance wise, he was a mess,
positionally, he was my son
and he was gonna be great.
And I'll change his diapers for him.
And I'll feed him in this process.
And I think we, in a state
of perpetual brokenness,
sometimes our performance seems poor,
and that's okay sometimes,
because it reminds us of our positioning.
And I think the strategy for me in a place
where I feel like I just can't get past
how ugly everything feels
and looks around me.
It made me that much more dependent.
And then I began to be
disciplined in dependency,
because I didn't have a choice, right?
If you've ever been sick or broken a limb,
you learn how to become
dependent on other people
or you learn how to function
in a new kind of way.
And that's what happened
to me in that state
is just constant dependency.
Dependency on God, dependency on friends,
kind of throwing myself on
the train tracks of faith.
And what that means is even
if it seems like black ink
on white pages, I'm just gonna read it.
I'm gonna read it. I'm
gonna keep reading it.
I'm gonna keep reading it
until it gets in me, you know?
And I'm gonna put myself
around people that I know mean
me well and not harm,
even if I don't feel
like being around them.
And I'm gonna fight to
become a dependent person
until it's like, oh wow.
I am out of this position. I'm healed.
Right?
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Hi.
Thanks for being here.
My question is sort of
on the flip side of kind
of dealing with haters
and people who don't
necessarily agree with you.
Kind of in your process
of rise to success,
how have you managed to stay humble?
And you're also talking
about a big part of mental
health being the communities
that you kind of go back
to for support.
Has that sort of rise to fame
made you alienated at all,
felt alienated like you can't,
like sort of people
can't maybe relate
to you in the way that they used to?
- First of all, I don't know
who told you I was humble.
(audience laughs)
I'm not, I'm constantly
practicing the art of humility.
It's a lifetime struggle.
So feel free to join me.
Yeah. So humility is just daily,
like reminding yourself...
I read a book on it every year.
I'll find a different one if I need to,
but there's just a lot of
different perspectives,
as a part of it is like
just reminding myself
of how big God is. And then
you are all, oh, I'm small.
That's good. This is a good reminder.
But yeah. And keeping
close friends around me.
So, to answer your question, yes,
I do keep close, day one,
original friends who know me as me,
not me who rose to whatever around
because they keep me humble.
It's very hard for them to
see the difference that like,
"Why do they want you to
autograph, that's stupid?"
You know what I mean?
(audience laughs)
So I keep those people around.
But then yes is hard because it takes them
a while to breathe that air, right?
It takes them a while
and they have to adjust.
Oprah said it once, she said, man,
my friends have struggled
to breathe my air.
And I was like, what is she talking about?
You know what I mean?
I just, I don't get it.
But then I did understand
it after a season.
And it's kinda like,
I'm leaving Jimmy Fallon
and my friends are like, yo,
let's stand outside and look
around and take pictures.
And I'm like, I can't do that. Right?
Like I'm...
There's, you know, there's
just different little things,
little nuances that
they have to learn like,
oh, that's right.
Your life sucks.
(audience laughs)
But then over time they,
I tell them and they
understand, they grasp it.
And then they serve me in that capacity
and they start trying to protect me.
And those are the people
that I want around,
people who don't try to take advantage
of the unique opportunities I have,
but wanna protect me
from other random stuff.
So yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
I am just in wonder,
'cause there's so many
elements that I wanna talk
about for like three
hours and there's, like,
just keep track on top of them.
But one of the things that,
a word that keeps coming
through this presentation,
through this town hall is wholeness.
I keep thinking returning
the brokenness and wholeness
and wholeness in brokenness.
But in this cultural section,
I feel as though a lot of times
I've also segmented
parts of myself and
ignored parts of myself.
And I feel as though I'm
in an environment here
at Yale, which encourages
me to walk on my hands,
and I get strong walking
on my hands, thinking,
not feeling, being able to analyze
and not empathize.
And I wanna ask, how do you stop yourself,
when you find yourself
continuing to walk on your hands,
continuing to go back to
that self that's only a part
of you and not the whole you?
- You already accomplished the first step
as you acknowledged,
you're plowing through,
you acknowledged that you're
walking on your hands.
Right?
I think it should be an encouragement
to you that when you said that,
how many people in this room groaned like,
"Ooh," you're not alone.
There's a room full of people
who are like, "I agree."
And I think you foster that
community and you become.
Look at me, man. I'm wearing pants.
You see these pants?
These don't make sense.
(audience laughs)
These don't make sense, but I don't care.
'Cause I like 'em. So I'm gonna wear them.
And my word, my value is not diminished.
Some people are saying,
"What is he wearing?"
yeah, he's a good artist.
It's what the artists do-
(audience laughs)
But I'm like, I wanna wear 'em.
So I wear 'em.
And I think it's that,
that's what a prestigious
institution builds.
Builds that kind of character,
that kind of authenticity that says,
I'm who I am and who I am is accepted.
And you have a community here that accepts
you and you're not fighting
for their acceptance.
You're not fighting for
anybody's acceptance.
You're being who you
authentically should be.
That's what success is, right?
And so I think it's resting
in those moans that you heard,
it's resting in all the people that you.
'Cause truthfully that's how
everybody's feeling, bro.
That's, they're all feeling that.
They're just afraid to show it.
They're afraid to say,
"I wanna be accepted by
everybody so I'm not gonna be
my real self."
(audience laughs)
They're afraid to say
that, but it's the truth.
Everyone's in a performance trap.
And we were talking earlier and I said,
the thing about you all here
is you're so exceptionally gifted
and you're in an arena where
all the emphasis is put
on how exceptionally gifted
you are academically.
But that doesn't mean
you're whole emotionally,
mentally, spiritually.
Right? Does it?
Why do they put a gym on campus?
'Cause they know. (indistinct)
So I'm just, it's okay.
Acknowledge it, live in it, walk in it,
breathe it in and own it, man, own that.
Own it, "I'm tired of walking on my hands.
I'm not gonna do it." And
there's other people around you.
That's how movements get started.
It's like a little video.
It's funny. It's like a guy
on a hillside, you know?
And he's like dancing
crazy in front of a bunch
of people just chilling
and looking at him like,
what is he doing?
But then the second
guy comes up and starts
dancing with them.
And then that second guy
is the person that starts
the movement, right?
It's all it takes is one other
person to stand beside you.
And after the second guy
in the third and the fourth
and the fifth and everyone else,
like I don't wanna be left
out, I don't wanna be left out.
They wanted to get up.
And they were so afraid of
what everyone else would say.
The group thing happened.
But the beauty of it
was somebody had to be
the first person to say, I
felt like dancing, I'm dancing.
So, more power to you,
you heard the moans.
We wish you, man.
- [Audience Member] Name's J. Maurice.
And I wanted to thank you.
I had to call my children
and ask them who Lecrae was,
so I wasn't sure, but they
told me to come anyway.
But one of the things that you mentioned,
and I think this is part of
the experience that we have,
is that we talk about the
church and going to the church.
And I think many of us
have gone to the church
and have felt neglected and abandoned.
And so one of the things you've done here,
you talk about transparency
and vulnerability.
And when you look at the
New Testament, you came
to Christ as you were.
I think so often where
we're afraid to do that.
And you talked about
authenticity and intentionality.
So I appreciate the fact
and now I'm asking him
what can I get from this?
But it's a reminder of me that
learning process is ongoing.
And this looks like a church
and we're having church,
because there's a level of
openness and transparency
that we can always have in the church.
And so I think,
as we take this away and I do
a lot of work with leaders,
we don't have this conversation,
because there's a sense of,
I can't let other folks know where I am.
And you also talk about our
community and our cultures.
A lot of our culture and
committees are surrounded
by violence, but we live in that space.
And so it becomes a commonplace thing.
But once you've created
here as a sense of...
And so for me, this is church.
This is what church is
supposed to be about.
And so I think that's
as we in here believe
to trust, to love, to
reach out to one another,
because people are hurting
and you've said that.
And if we can create that sense of church,
I think where we are, it's important.
But I'm curious in terms
of when did you come
into that space where
you realize your faith
and what that meant to you?
What, was the place or
time when you just stepped
into that space and said, you know what?
I'm gonna be me. This is
who God created me to be.
And if anyone else has problem with it,
that's their problem.
When did you come into that
space was like, you know what?
This is who I am.
- Yeah. I think over
the last two years is...
I've always acknowledged my faith,
since I became a believer,
but I think over the last two
years, it wasn't group think,
it wasn't going along with everyone's,
what people will pat me on the back for.
And because I grew up
fatherless and I'm not saying
that's the reason for everyone's
situation, but for me,
that was the ingredient for
my desire for acceptance
and approval, was because I
didn't get that affirmation.
Like no one ever said,
"Son, I wanna tell you did a good job."
I never heard that. So I
longed to hear it somewhere.
And it wasn't until I said,
oh, God already said that.
You know what I mean? God
already said, "I love you."
And I'm proud of you, and
keep going, keep trusting me.
And you don't have it all
together, but that's okay. I do.
Oh, that's freeing. That's liberating.
Well, let me just be
who I'm supposed to be.
And I think, unfortunately for me,
I had to go through hell to get there.
Right? I had to be pushed
to the edge of insanity.
So I was left with no choice.
I don't want that for anybody.
I don't want anybody to get to
the ledge and be like, well,
I hopefully that people will, like I said,
be broken before you are
broken, you know what I mean?
That's what my hope would
be for everybody. So...
- Yeah. One more.
- [Audience Member] Hello.
So I guess my question is
I was just speaking with my step son
about my challenges of
balancing my work life
and my personal life.
And so my main challenge is
that I feel like everybody
has a need for me.
And I have to be,
I have to wear a million
hats and I have to be
100 different places.
And how do I be able to
take care of my own self
and take time out for
myself when I have so many
people that have all
these demands on myself?
- It's good. Every scenario is different.
So I can't speak to your
specific circumstances, right?
I can speak in generalities
and I can speak
about my experience.
And for me, what I've had to
do is, like I said before,
I think sometimes busyness means
we're out of control, right?
So it's taking back some of the control,
and a large part of that, for me,
has been creating,
prioritizing space for rest,
prioritizing space for self care.
It's not me being selfish.
It's me actually trying to
care about everyone else.
And if I'm gonna lose my
mind, I'm no good for y'all.
So I prioritize it,
and we prioritize lots of things, right?
If you're involved in any
kind of extracurricular,
you somehow found a way to
prioritize that and to put
that in your life.
If you're caught up on any Netflix series,
you've prioritized that to
make that a part of your life.
So it's prioritizing
those breaks in my life.
And it's putting them on a calendar saying
you can't touch it.
Nothing can touch this.
Oh, what are you doing?
I'm walking through a graveyard
in the middle of the day,
'cause nobody will talk to me.
And if it's weird, I don't care.
(audience laughs)
But nothing can touch that.
I might as well be at the
hospital visiting my sick mother,
you can't touch that time.
And so it's been for me
creating those spaces
where I'm like, if I don't get this,
I'm gonna lose my mind.
So I've gotta create this
space that just has to happen.
And so even with...
I give my wife Tuesdays off.
So Tuesdays I'm like, go,
live life. I got them.
Everything. Don't even come
home from sunup to sundown.
I don't, you don't have
any responsibilities.
(audience laughs)
Like, you know what I'm saying? Like...
No, literally she'll come home
in the middle of the day
and the house is on fire
and I got kids everywhere and stuff.
And then they'll be like, "Mommy."
She says, I don't exist, bye.
And she'll just like walk
through the house, but it's like,
but we created that
space, where it's, like,
nothing, nothing can stop it.
And so no matter what opportunity
or whatever, it's like,
this is blocked.
Right? You know what I mean?
And so that's what I
would say is just create,
like prioritize, whatever
it needs to be prioritized
for you to feed your soul,
feed your mind, your emotion,
your health, whatever it is.
- I'm gonna help us to
transition into ongoing work
and ongoing conversation.
And I will ask Lecrae to give
us thoughts to send us off.
And I will invite my university chaplain,
Sharon Kugler, up to close.
Lecrae mentioned, that
is the second person
who stands beside the first person
that starts the movement.
I recognize tonight that
we are the second person.
And some of you in this room
are the first person. Who...
You've been having these conversations.
You've been doing this work.
You may have created resources.
You may have created space for this type.
And one of the things I've learned
about Yale for my time here
is that I don't know all
that I should know about
what opportunities exist
and who else may be
interested in something
that I'm interested in.
There is some comments
tonight that I think some
of you may have heard and said,
I'm actually doing well in that area.
And I'm willing to share
how I'm having victory
in that area.
And there's some of you
tonight who might've
heard something and said, you know what?
This has been a pain in
my existence for a while,
but I'm willing to step out and say,
this is a pain in my existence and I wanna
conquer this thing.
Is anybody open to that?
You have index cards, there
are more index cards available
if you would like them.
I would like to receive,
and we would like to receive
your contact information.
And what is that work that you're doing?
What are those conversations
that you're having,
or that you want to
start having around any
of these topics or other topics?
And my promise to you,
it's hard making a promise.
My promise to you is to
collect that and send it back
to every registrant who provided
an email address, to say,
this is where we can continue
the conversation on campus.
And this is the work that we can do.
And I know that there are professionals
in the audience who think
about these topics often.
And I would like a way to,
just to harvest your
generosity and to share
it in ways that allow you
to keep your mental health
in ways that support you.
So if there's an index
card that you would like,
please ask, if there's a
pen that you would like,
please ask, and we'll
collect it before it's over.
If you did not provide your email address,
but you would like to
receive that information,
please also write that on an index card
and we will collect it.
So I ask Lecrae to send
us off with something
and then Sharon to come forward.
- All I will say before I exit is like,
I'm gonna leave,
but you're gonna continue
to be here wrestling,
and so I think it's very
crucial that you make
these connections, and
with the leadership,
the wisdom in this room and one another,
and really foster this community,
because it's very easy for
somebody like me to pop in,
drop a bomb.
Everyone's like yeah, that's good.
And then I leave and that's it.
But it's, hopefully I'm
here just as an inspiration
for you to continue doing
what you're already doing
and to continue to do more than that.
So that's my hope and my prayer,
that when I come back next
time it'll be even greater.
So yeah.
- Thank you.
And those of you who are
willing to share your story
and to be in conversation with someone,
just to be that vulnerable, please say so.
(indistinct)
- I just wanna thank
everyone who came out.
I wanna especially thank
OrLando and Nii who became new
good old friends in these last few months,
thank you for all the work that you did
for all the volunteers.
Thank you to Kim for coming.
And Lecrae, thank you for
the gift of your words
and your presence and your spirit.
And as you were speaking,
I was thinking, he's taking
words and he's reinvented
them to the good, and in particular,
I was thinking about failure
as birth, as a beginning,
that when you talked about building
on that and lifting your brokenness,
it's something we all
need to hear at this place
that demands perfection,
which I think can finish us,
but failure can begin us.
And so you gave that to us tonight.
I wanna invite you all to
take a deep breath. (exhales)
We're going back out there.
But we're not going back out there alone.
We shared some important things tonight.
I thank you for your bravery.
That's another word that we need to claim
to a different end.
A bravery that's radical
in how far and wide
we embrace others and how far and wide
we embrace ourselves and our brokenness.
So God bless each and every one of you,
go in peace and breathe.
Good night.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)